in the opening scene we are introduced
to a journalist named Justin Sanderson
who is known for his investigative
prowess he is currently at the airport
preparing for his journey to Tel Aviv
Israel as he enters the terminal he
notices a familiar book resting on a
shelf titled the end of Civility turns
out the book is his own creation curious
Justin makes his way towards the
bookshelf only to stumble upon a fellow
traveler named Joe Beaumont Joe
recognizes Justin immediately and says
that he is a big fan of his work he then
excitedly asks for an autograph showing
appreciation for his fan support Justin
personally buys a copy of his book and
signs it for Joe later on while waiting
in the airport terminal Justin talks
with his wife over the phone she appears
to be sad about his departure claiming
that she will be lonely however Justin
explains that he has witnessed something
highly unusual which has persuaded him
to go on this journey and gather more
information about it as the two continue
talking A peculiar series of
coincidences catches his attention the
date today is October 15th and the
flight number is 10 15. furthermore an
unexpected delay in the departure time
means that the plane will now be taking
off at 10 15 instead of 9 30. careful
Justin you don't want to jump the shark
like Jim Carrey after a while the
passengers including Justin proceed to
board the awaiting flight as he steps
inside he notices a family having
difficulties with their seat
Arrangements they are struggling to
adjust their children surprisingly
Justin offers his own seat to the family
generously accommodating their needs he
then retreats to the main cabin
compartment where he reunites with Joe
just as Justin settles into his new seat
he discovers A peculiar MP3 player
hidden behind the seat in front of him
intrigued by it he plugs in a pair of
earphones and starts playback of a
podcast entitled enigmatic featuring an
episode titled the tragic mystery of
Flight 1015. surprisingly the narrator
is talking about this very flight just
like I am whoa he says that in the next
hour the flight will vanish from the
radar never to be seen again hearing
this Justin becomes intrigued and he
continues with the podcast the narrator
of enigmatique then reveals the name of
the flight Captain which is Donner this
finally makes Justin worried so he urges
a fellow passenger to listen to the
podcast hoping that he's wrong however
the man rudely refuses and relocates to
a different seat instead due to this
Justin finds himself compelled to
continue listening to the podcast unable
to shake off the mounting unease in the
next chapter the narrator foretells that
a bird will collide with the aircraft
precisely at 10 21 to Justin's
astonishment and horror a bird indeed
strikes the plane at that exact
designated time intensifying his
panic-stricken state in a desperate bid
to regain composure he rushes to the
restroom and tries to calm himself by
repetitively reassuring himself that the
past is the past he then contorts his
body to the shape that 1015 would make
on a clock and takes a dump after this
Justin goes back to his seat and calls
one of the flight attendants seeking
clarification regarding the bird
accident and the peculiar engine noise
however the flight attendant claims to
know nothing about such incidents he
even declines Justin's request to talk
to the captain claiming he doesn't want
to create an unnecessary scene in
response Justin shouts in Anger
something which he hasn't done all of
his life but he soon realizes his
mistake and apologizes to the flight
attendant assuring him that he will shut
up with this sense of composure Justin
resumes the podcast in which the
narrator ominously declares that the
airplane will vanish at precisely 11 15
with the Pilot's final words good night
New York hearing this the poor guy
becomes even more agitated and Restless
so Justin finally gets up in search of
some Clues he soon discovers that the
passengers on this flight can see the
pilots in the cockpit through an array
of cameras the podcast further explains
that a device interfering with the
flight's Communication System may be
responsible for the perplexing
circumstances filled with suspicion
Justin fixates on two foreign men who
are busy on their devices he then
approaches them and rudely asks them to
turn off their phones the podcast is
exposing Justin's racism however in
response the two men assert that their
phones are on airplane mode this makes
Justin upset and he gets into an
argument with them until flight
attendants intervene instructing him to
return to his assigned seat following
this Justin delves deeper into the
podcast and learns about a gentleman
named Igor orloff a fellow passenger on
the same flight to Tel Aviv turns out he
is going to testify against the Russian
mafia this makes Justin suspect that the
flight may have been sabotaged due to
the mafia's involvement but he also
thinks that there is a high chance of
the presence of an undercover U.S air
marshal on board who would possess
crucial knowledge regarding the safety
of the aircraft with this newfound
information in mind Justin for one more
time goes to a flight attendant and
requests to speak with the air marshal
however the flight attendant
understandably annoyed by his persistent
inquiries asks him for a huge favor to
remain in his seat with no one to listen
Justin goes to and confides in him Joe
being a pilot himself says that the Air
Marshals often possess a similarly
deceptive mindset to that of terrorists
inadvertently persuading Justin to
investigate the Russian passengers
belongings Justin then sneaks into the
Russian passenger's luggage compartment
and begins checking their bags while
they are asleep the other passengers in
the plane notice this but Justin doesn't
stop as he attempts to open the overhead
cabin he unintentionally drops a bag on
one of the Russian passengers this
causes a scene and the two men start
arguing just then Justin spills at the
fact that the Russian mafia intends to
execute Igor orlov sending everyone into
a state of panic even Igor orlov himself
emerges from the first class section
worried and scared in order to resolve
the situation Captain Donner walks out
of the cockpit and warns Justin against
causing further problems the other
passengers also start recording him
forcing Justin to silently return to his
seat following this he turns the podcast
back on and the narrator shockingly
reveals that Justin is the one who is
directly linked to the flight's
Disappearance in addition he plays the
audio of Justin's previous altercation
with the Russian passengers this leaves
our protagonist completely speechless
but before he can react Captain Donner
takes him to the flight attendant's Dock
and talks to him about his erratic
behavior however Justin continues
arguing and warns the captain not to
utter the phrase goodnight New York as
it will be the last thing they hear
before the flight vanishes this
convinces the captain that Justin is
mentally unstable and experiencing a
psychotic episode shortly after the air
marshal finally reveals her identity and
arrests Justin for threatening the
entire flight Justin is now seated
alongside the U.S air marshal who tells
him that he will receive immediate
psychological assistance once they land
nevertheless Justin still tries to
convince her that he is not undergoing
any form of mental breakdown and asserts
that he possesses evidence of what is
about to unfold however this is not
enough to persuade the air marshal she
then goes to the pilot for a discussion
while she is Away Joe approaches Justin
and and expresses his belief in him he
also suggests that the mere fact of
being aboard this plan signifies the
realm of possibilities after careful
consideration Justin proposes that Joe
being a pilot himself take control of
the aircraft and land it in Canada or
somewhere safer before it vanishes but
for this Joe requires a passcode to
access the cockpit Justin is pretty
confident that the code is 10 15. since
everything that is happening here
revolves around that number with this
information Joe enters the cockpit
incapacitates the captain and forcefully
takes the control of the plane's
operations this instills Panic among the
passengers but before they can react Joe
lowers the cabin's air pressure
eventually causing everyone to lose
Consciousness in a shocking turn of
events he then utters The Haunting words
good night New York later we see Justin
walking up on the shore of an island
with a floating doll next to him it
becomes evident that their flight has
crash landed on water Justin freaks out
and looks around but no other people are
in site shortly after he discovers the
same MP3 player and decides to Play It
Again the podcast narrator continues to
recount the second part of flight 1015
as per the narration an extensive search
was conducted for the flight but the
efforts were in vain after several days
a cargo ship fortunately discovered a
small strip of land where all the
survivors except for one had managed to
stay alive the narrator mentions that
Justin Sanderson was reported missing as
he could not be found anywhere on the
desolate Island at the same Moment
Justin looks up and spots the entire
flight crew and passengers approaching
him understandably enraged by the
circumstances they hold Justin
responsible for the plane crash and
begin to assault him physically this
results in his unfortunate death it's
okay though it wasn't real it was just
an episode of a TV show about an author
who's listening to a podcast that was
made by somebody and then the whole
thing was written up by our writer and
then I told it Adam Scott is fine watch
Severance subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching